vamos a ver cuánto es 6.3 dividido entre
0.25 cuando veo algo como esto lo
primero que quiero hacer es deshacerme
de este punto decimal para que en lugar
de estar dividiendo por 25 centésimas o
dividida entre 2.5 yo pueda hacer la
división con un número entero que sería
25 como convierto 25 centésimas en 25 si
multiplicó por 10 una vez voy a tener
que nuevo el punto decimal un lugar a la
derecha y se multiplicó por 10 dos veces
voy a tener que el punto decimal se
mueve dos lugares a la derecha
así que 25 centésimas se va a convertir
en 25 multiplique por 10 dos veces que
es lo mismo que multiplicar por 100
ahora por supuesto que esto no puedo
hacerlo solamente con este número con el
0.25 esto cambiaría el valor de esta
operación así que tengo que hacer lo
mismo con 6.3 sin move y el punto
decimal dos lugares a la derecha en esta
parte para obtener un número entero
también tengo que mover el punto decimal
dos veces aquí si nuevo el punto decimal
una vez voy a tener 63 pues estoy
multiplicando por 10 y quiero moverlo
hacia la derecha otra vez pero ustedes
me pueden decir oye aquí ya no hay otro
número como es que puedo mover el punto
a la derecha otra vez pues tenemos que
recordar que 6.3 va a ser lo mismo que
6.30 y puedo yo agregar cualquier
cantidad de ceros a la derecha de este
número y no me va a cambiar el valor de
este número va a seguir siendo 6.3 6
enteros con 3 décimas es lo mismo que 6
enteros 30 centésimas así que ahora
puedo mover el punto decimal un lugar
más hacia la derecha multiplicó por 10
de nuevo y ahora voy a tener 630 así que
6.3 dividido entre 0.25 es lo mismo que
tener 630 dividido entre 25
vamos a hacerlo de nuevo porque esta es
la parte donde todo el mundo se confunde
cuando estamos dividiendo entre
decimales si yo tengo 0.25 que va a
dividir a 6.3 lo que me interesa es
mover este punto decimal hacia la
derecha luz suficiente para aquí tener
un número entero no tengo que moverlo
más allá solo lo suficiente para que
tenga yo aquí un entero y aquí tendremos
que mover el punto decimal el mismo
número de veces que lo hicimos de este
otro lado nuestra meta es convertir esto
en un número entero no a este lado
aunque esto va a ocurrir para este
ejemplo en particular si me muevo dos
lugares hacia la derecha 12 0.25 se
convierte en 25 y el 6.3 se convierte en
nuevo aquí un lugar lo muevo otro lugar
se convierte en 630 bueno y ahora vamos
a limpiar un poco esto para dejarlo más
claro borramos esto de acá
para que no nos confunda todo esto que
escribí
y también todo esto de acá que ya no me
sirve
y ya estamos listos para hacer nuestra
división larga
es tener un número de dos dígitos que
divide a un número de tres dígitos
así que 25 cada vez 0 veces en 6
continuamos 25 kv cuántas veces en 63
pues si va a caber algunas veces ya que
63 es más grande que 25 bueno 25 por 12
50 25 por 3 75 75 es más grande así que
ya no nos sirve tendríamos que
multiplicar por 22 por 25 va a ser igual
a 50 y lo podemos restar o si no saben
que 2 por 25 es 50 pues multiplicamos 2
por 510 llevamos 12 por 24 más una que
llevamos 5 y ahora hacemos la resta 3 -0
es 365 es 1 nos queda 13 y ahora bajamos
el siguiente dígito bajamos el 0 y
podemos decir que 25 de hecho permíteme
tachar esto porque ya no nos sirve
cuántas veces cabe el 25 en el 130 bueno
si 25 por 4 es 100 25 por 5
125 25 por 6 sería igual a 150 que ya es
muy grande nos pasamos pues cada vez 5
veces y lo escribo de manera que pueda
yo dar seguimiento a mis lugares de
valor a mis posiciones de valor baje el
cero para convertir el 13 en 130 y si yo
digo que 25 caben 135 veces tengo que
escribir este 5 encima de este cero así
que 5 por 25 ya sabemos cuánto es pero
vamos a hacerlo paso a paso para no
confundirnos 5 por 5 es 25 llevo 25 por
12 10 más 2 que llevaba son 12 y ahora
podemos restar y pueden darse cuenta que
130 menos 125 pues va a ser 5 o si
quieren pueden reagrupar un poco las
cantidades aquí de manera que tomo una
decena de este 3 y este 0 lo transformó
en 10 10 menos 55
2 - 2011 es 0 pero todavía no hemos
terminado queremos dividir esto por
completo así que podemos bajar otro 0 y
estoy eligiendo un color para este otro
paso y quiero agregar otro 0 pero tengo
que tener mucho cuidado porque no puedo
poner el 0 así tal cual aquí ya que me
cambiaría el 630 a 6.300 así que tengo
que ser muy cuidadoso de poner aquí un
punto decimal y pondré el 0 después de
este punto decimal así que 630 es lo
mismo que 630 + 0 décimas y si aquí
agregue un punto decimal también lo
tengo que hacer aquí arriba tenemos que
ser muy cuidadosos con esto y bueno
ahora ya puedo bajar este 0
ahora tenemos 50 cuántas veces cabe el
25 en el 50 vamos a borrar estos que
también ya no nos sirve 25 cabe
exactamente dos veces en 50 pues 2 por
25 es igual a 50 ahora podemos restar 50
menos 50 es igual a 0 y ya no tengo nada
más que bajar aquí
ya que tenemos nuestro residuo igual a 0
con esto terminamos nuestra división por
completo
tomamos 630 dividido entre 25 y el
resultado es 25 puntos 2
o si vemos nuestro problema original 6.3
dividido entre 0.25 también va a ser
igual a 25.2
vamos a reescribir lo nuestro problema
original era 6.3 dividido entre 0.25 y
encontramos que es igual a 25.2 o 25 con
dos décimas y con esto hemos terminado